we didn't come to all these everyone all
right good evening welcome right I'll
just read out from the usual advice
please note this meeting will be audio
recorded should we be required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the run by the door to the fire
escape staircase please hold those
handrails in case the stairs wet or
slippery if anyone is unable to use the
stairs where they please allow others to
exit the room before they go to the fire
escape door rather they can then be
given assistance now assembly point will
be in the public car part at the side of
the Civic sweet please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings and
please do not return to the dueling
engine until given permission to do so
by capsule staff by good evening
everyone welcome preparing all right
here we go then right so apologies for
absence tune on the other leaders at the
moment any others know normal is tending
we've got a counselor Gooding & cash or
very welcome minutes of the meeting held
on the fifth of October there are a
couple of minutes yes Sherman just just
just minor they should be showing
councillor Gooding as visiting that
meeting and indeed show Rob Manning as
present as well thank you Jim college
kids because while your presence okay so
other than those amendments members are
you happy to for me to sign them as a
true recollections rectory thank you
wrote any declarations of interest
please if anything arises during the
meeting please declare it then we'll
make sure it's annotated well item five
meses refer to the executive and reports
from other committees there are none
just losophy picture flip it and go
straight into I some six then and get it
yeah well item 6 in which he reported me
a 15 melissa and i believe for something
you're going to obviously show this one
just mad mmm next our role Rob will take
you through the detail for the first
thing that you'll notice and that a
number of members have commented on
already there's a two point forward but
a slightly different format of
presenting information which allows for
a greater degree of transparency with
all the different things that were doing
were putting in there all the vet all
the variations from the original set
budget if anyone's got any specific
details are wishes any any specific
details on any of them please do do ask
but as far as I'm concerned it's that
bottom line that is most important one
that shows that there is still a savings
being made and the rest of the the
report goes through the various bits of
detail about how how we've gone through
in court too it's not been easy but it's
relatively optimistic news problem take
you through the rest of the league
average wish okay okay there's always
I'll start any questions we'd probably
go as we go through it'll be easier so
and so Thank You Jan and it's a free
open up a report like that says as its
council committees just outlined and
we've put in the table at the front
which is now around all of the the
international reserves that you wouldn't
necessarily have seen before
and not it less aside if there's any non
transparency before but now we are very
clear on how the budget is moved between
the various times over the year from the
original point to where we are now in q2
and you will see same very similar for
q3 and then eventually find way out
there and what this does it had some
says it just gives us that that
transparency so you can ask questions
you can see how we have moved money
between reserves and the general fund
revenue account as such and and so we've
got complete audit trail from our point
of view as well that everyone is aware
of what has gone so as it's on Tates
their own questions first of all on that
table I'm happy to answer please just
can you just play time sorry the 24601
to my member 16 371 required to come
across as a shaman let's start blighted
they were two cases so I think I can
don't object now I can talk ok no jitter
they are tuned legal cases that we
settle but will not starve allotted us
and so I take it offline after fighting
again don't presumably I mean there are
no dates on these so when we skip the
next loses report yeah will we see the
same ones again oh this it once you've
seen these now that will be gone it
would only be the new ones it's just the
fact we've done this for the first time
to do this you've seen a big a big
enough yet missing much ok and where you
see the same sort of thing happening
again I think for instance I think on
the top of page 63 there's one they're
very small around 1300 odd HR advice and
there's another one somewhere about
human resources separate absolutely yeah
and again it's for that clarity so we
can see where the winner was approval
and we've got the back up to it to its
right then you see there's an IT one as
well fifteen thousand and fifteen
thousand five hundred that's not tight
are they were these very distinct things
okay so just to clarify ringing a second
just to clarify so these are things if
you like that our moral assignments from
one form to another that are actually
broad
if you like and that's showing that work
you know low it was a listed under one
thing we've actually transfer the over
to cover the cost of another it's yes so
basically this is where we have money
input side in a reserve subway it's done
is it's added budget to our baseline
budget as such and then we've spent
against that budget so if we hadn't have
done this it will just shown as
potential in August position but the
artist actually was a fully agreed
position to build the money down I
sightings in effect and spent that so
yes that's a lot of research please yeah
again if I might just come back to the
issue that counselor rogers brought up
with regard to the government's the
legal reserve on those two items again
this is really proves certain arguments
that we put forward at certain times by
certain people in regards to
transparency where there are items that
are now shown in the transparency
section but the reasons behind them are
actually priming confidential and so
they cannot be shown as such but we've
been totally transparent in showing that
there is something there and it
fortunately that's the differential
between the two arguments that are
coming up and are all coming up a vital
can I just add one little bit of
information there it's really important
that we don't in a budget allocate an
amount for a settlement because
otherwise you're pretty determining what
that settles it might be a settlement
could go either way depending on the
relevant factors of the case if you
allocated a back and see if there's a
predetermination so these sort of things
will always come from reserve absolutely
just a toss point I think there was a
contingency reserve in any of it isn't
there just to cover
goes to anything I completely understand
okay that's fine yeah I mean just as a
as a to give you some confidence there
to be honest if this page was a hundred
hundred items long that wouldn't
actually reflect in any way good or bad
on the planet were standing of the
organization these are in most cases one
off items that have ever been planned
for so therefore we've got reserve in
place as such or something which is
unknown but we put money aside for it
this is exactly how you should deal with
these sorts of things what you don't
want to do is put in lots of money into
your base budget for potential turn one
offs and contingency because that's
quite dangerous by budgeting so this is
actually a much better way of doing it
is transparency you put on your side in
your reserve savings account can you
just draw down to it the things that you
need that you were expecting so it's
absolutely the right way to do things so
it shouldn't be seen as a negative
that's one try get across okay thank you
very much any other questions please
write members go back to 1.1 novella
quarter to 16 17 revenue budget and
capitalization contained in paragraph 3
& 4 as shown in appendix 1 and 2 so an
agreed upon 2 to 16 17 capital melissa
report in appendix 2 and so the current
financial performance on key revenue
financial indicators as shown in
appendices three and four all you want
agreement with that very very much
indeed lets it go to item 7 should be
right so this is about the voluntary
sector brands I did ask sound varies
because normally you make these
decisions in well the actual decisions
on how they are apportioned in December
but I understand we don't do it that way
well it's a change we could we shouldn't
do it anyway we're determined but uh I
felt it was much more appropriate so set
to allocate grands after the budget of
insect it was the other way around
previously where we would set the
grounds prior to the budget being set
and that was an anomaly we do have some
rigid restrictions if we're going to
significantly alter any any of our big
recipients grants but I haven't said
without determining which way the grants
will go i haven't sense that there's any
any big flavor for playing around too
much of the amount of budget that we
have a gate towards grants so the
applications will be going out shortly
and they'll be in place so that as soon
as the British needs is set the grounds
can be determined do you think very much
any questions please yes please with
regards to the larger recipients and I
think in a particularly Reds and CA B we
have here they receive from us a lot of
what are referred to as gifts in kind I
parking spaces and help with rent and
rates what have you although it doesn't
come up against air and now that we give
them from the pot is it allocated
against than what that value is that we
do give them by other means
yeah I'll be honest either it's not
tonight i'm really looked into but i did
my first time oh it had it has written
in the past here the developer value has
break but the nature of it means that it
is quite difficult to be definitive yeah
but when the officer is doing the report
on the individual organizations the
totality of what they they receive is
considered so absolutely at anything to
help okay okay now that's something a
figure that should be mentioned within
errone to sum up at the end of the year
if you like because I think that's a I
suppose you could call it a gifting kind
I mean if its premises using its use of
parking spaces if it's help it might
just be like electric and water you know
now that that's sort of thing we are
hating so you know I think you can you
can in the same way that you know he's
ever recharge relating to any of the
department's here you can probably
allocate it in the similar sort of way
for that business election you know I
believe there has been a discussion
amongst members with regard to some sort
of ad hoc discretion on a pot or an
amount as put aside but very small
donations to some or the very smaller
charities that are out there which maybe
don't have the wherewithal to put in a
proper application per site and it may
only be maybe 50 pounds or a hundred
pounds would we be looking or when we
could consider a sum that could be used
as an ad hoc amount where we have small
charities and small things that are
going on around the district where they
can apply where they don't necessarily
have to go through this robust rigmarole
it could be a lighter touch is there
something that we can put in interview
and we could we could sound there's an
obviously my initial thought would be as
long as it's within the existing and
pop the such a bore out the other rooms
with charity sector money would be my
concern is and I'll be totally honest is
fraud and about the reputation yes or
not that's why I do appreciate input in
putting in low monetary values but I
suppose at what point does it become far
more for us to do something different
it's it's yeah you something thank you
everybody I think that that that's
something that we won't be ready for
this year not but I think if we're if
we're in the position to do grants again
next year which we obviously hope that
we won't be then that is something that
we won't be able to be looking to do in
some form or another not sure if all you
steadily and John's prompted me on this
blessing just to say only is within the
gift i think is a portfolio holder and
perhaps with it you know the portfolio a
hold of community as well you know we've
been advice to each other to sort of
take that forward and have the format in
which they want to do then I one of the
problems is I mean we do get people who
apply for grants for a literary a few
hundred pounds but there's a bit of form
filling for that and some of the smaller
organizations you know it wouldn't
necessarily have the wherewithal all the
kudos if you like to do that I know that
a drooling looks into all of these
things and the financial stability of
its are these organizations some of
which do have large balances you know do
we necessarily need to support them and
and I think that's something perhaps we
could consider you know I sort of you
know sort of Mark to from the as less
detail but I accept what you say about
the fraud side of it and I think Andrew
blessing would never really play
anything out but that's absolutely
invoicing will also saying to me I know
this because you've entered it to us
where we've had funds that are carried
forward because no universe or anything
has been presented a new assignment okay
if a little bit of time can be given
turn to work on what the best best
format is because obviously we don't
want it to be based on things that we
just happen to come across all people
who just happen to know
drivers we want something that we can
tell the community about so I think
inappropriate tired and it would be to
have a launch one we've had a chance to
just sit down and think of all the all
the practicalities and and potential
down forms and advantages of what a
scheme i look like a poppy thank you any
other questions please write so decision
this is so it basically putting a place
a procedure for allocating their
electric cautery sector bronze the next
year open applications the small grant
scheme for all community and voluntary
groups and if on the Oxford raelia
district association voluntary services
will receive top slice funding from the
same pot based on previous performance
so our members agreed on that ravenna
rude thank you very much indeed I think
that's the final paper so thank you very
much we're done all done